عمليه الهجوم وحاله التاهب الجوي هي
مستمره في الاراضي الاوكرانيه سواء كان في
العاصمه او في المدن الاخرى كانت قد اطلقت
القوات الروسيه في الليله الماضيه 15
طائره مسيره من طراز شاهد نحو مناطق
مختلفه في الاراضي الاوكرانيه استطاع
الدفاع الجوي الاوكراني ان يسقط 13 طائره
منها وطائرتين اصابته اهدافهما هنا في
الاراضي الاوكرانيه هذا من جانب اما عمليه
التاهب من ومخافه اطلاق الصواريخ كما تقول
نتاليا وهي ناطق الرسمي باسم القوات
القياده العملياتيه في الجنوب تقول ان
حركه السفن وحركه الخواصات في البحر
الاسود للجيش الروسي تنذر بان هنالك يعني
استعداد لعمليه استهداف ولكن طبعا هم
يؤكدون ايضا ان عمليه استهداف واسعه
النطاق التي كانت في السابق الان الاتحاد
الروسي غير قادر عليها لانه غير قادر على
عمليه الانتاج لهذه الصواريخ بالسرعه
المطلوبه